and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
welcome to Tim Dylan is going to hell
everybody we are here in beautiful Los
Angeles California it is a sunset
podcast how about that if you're
watching this we don't know if we're
putting it out video wise but if if we
put it out and you are watching it it's
a sunset podcast right here looking over
the beautiful hills not of Hollywood we
can't afford that but of an undisclosed
location we won't share with you because
many of you might get cute and come see
us especially if I say something you
don't like
I'm here with Benjamin Avery Ben Avery
is the producer of pretty much
everything I do all of those videos he's
the co-creator of all of those videos
that you love he edits them he's very
funny he produces this podcast and he is
trance and it is that is the most
important thing to me that is why I
hired him because his trance his other
skills were completely a surprise his
ability to help me in this business uh
and to create really cool stuff was
again secondary tertiary to be honest I
hired him because he was transient
because he was brave and I wanted to be
around somebody who was trans I didn't
know that he could edit videos I didn't
know that he could do anything like that
that is an added bonus for me personally
so thank you I was gonna say sir but
thank you person I like great to be here
in Los Angeles California we had a lot
of fun thanks to you and I forget the
guys name thanks to the guy who made
that master class clip which I posted on
YouTube if you listened to the last
podcast I spent a fair amount of time
illuminating the grift that is master
class this scam where essentially they
get people that you love and respect and
admire they get geniuses to come and con
you in your own home through YouTube
it's like the final insult you know it's
like these people that you love and that
you've watched their movies and you've
watched their comedy they hand them
boatloads of money to set
but class where they tell you all of the
wisdom that they have learned in their
career and you I guess through osmosis
take that wisdom in and do with it who
knows what we don't know that's the
point nobody has really gone that far
yet do you become David Lynch I don't
know maybe you're just interested in
filmmaking and instead of buying a book
you go to a master class I would be
totally cool with this if it was people
that were just interested in topics I
don't think that's what it is I think
there's a lot of people out there like
my mother who's a schizophrenic when
when I would watch her at night after
midnight
QVC the home shopping network that that
whole they take the gloves off when it
comes to marketing after midnight they
know they know who they're marketing to
after 12 a.m.
QVC just starts throwing [ __ ] out of
people they come out and they're like
this is Jacqueline Kennedy's engagement
we're like crazy [ __ ] that isn't true
and my mother would sit in her chair
with her phone out and scribbling into a
notebook writing down the numbers of all
of these things and then calling up and
spending just charging she didn't have
any money she was charging on QVC so I
think a lot of those people will be
purchasing masterclass I think that's
the demo I don't think the demo is
rational people that want to appreciate
another art form I think the demo is
people that tweet it marvel they're like
let me direct the next one I've seen
that I've seen people tweet at Marvel
hey let me get in there let me get in
there and direct the next movie in your
billion-dollar franchise these are
people that live amongst you some of
them aren't trolls it's easy to think
everyone's a troll they're not there's
some genuine lunatics walking the earth
there's this guy on Facebook I know am I
gonna say his name but he's clearly
unwell and he would tweet at Marvel like
put me in the gate list and he would
tweet a very serious thing and you're
like and then you look at the rest of
his stuff you're like oh it's obvious
he's not a troll and you know but
masterclass
I was [ __ ] on master class even a
lot of people that I respect are doing
it and I would also do it this is what I
don't ever want you people to not get
about me and about what I preach
if master class came to me with $400
okay now they went to all these other
people with a lot of money but if they
came to me with like 400 a month just a
few pokeballs essentially and I had to
come and hit you people over the head I
would absolutely do it you would see me
smiling and I'd go well the thing about
comedy and podcasting is the tapes fall
all the time I don't need a lot of money
they could convince me so easily could
just pull me in a room ago listen [ __ ]
these people that's all they'd have to
say and I go you're right you're right
what about yeah they go what are you a
[ __ ] school boy get in there teach a
master class I don't give a [ __ ] you
people really the majority of you don't
deserve a government you don't you don't
deserve a a a an entertainment industry
you don't so the idea that you you don't
deserve to be dealt with honestly you
deserve master class that's what you get
that's what you get so if they came to
me I would feel shitty about it for a
half a second and then they'd write a
check and I would [ __ ] dance my fat
ass in that [ __ ] YouTube room and I
would spout whatever garbage I would say
join the Platinum tier be an Excelsior
member of the master class do you want
the real good wisdom and so just know
that know that I'm not I'm not a saint
here which you know but a guy on
Instagram made a really cool parody of
the master class and he pulled things
from the podcast that I've said and it
was a lot of fun and and I talked on the
last podcast a little bit about the
melee innopolis thing at the creek and I
listened to some of the episode and it's
funny he's pretty funny he's ridiculous
he's he's a crazy guy that's his thing
what
I then did on the plane to LA as I
listened to the podcast he did with
Jordan Peterson and him and Jordan
Peterson and it points it was somewhat
contentious because I think Jordan
Peterson had said something about him
that Milo didn't really like they didn't
really get into that but Peterson then
subsequently apologised to Milo about it
this was when Milo was essentially taken
if you don't know Milo is Mila Milo who
cares
he was a provocateur he was a tech
writer from Breitbart which was Steve
bannon's in a media company which is
backed by Robert Rebecca Mercer they're
a father-daughter team Robert Mercer is
a billionaire he lives in Long Island
New York where I'm from him and his
daughter are conservative and they back
Breitbart financially they pull the
strings they're the money guys behind
Breitbart and the same way that I think
you know the Koch family is behind like
Shapiro and The Daily wire and a turning
point in all that stuff behind all of
these things just away on the left Soros
is behind behind all of these outfits
his money it's big money and at people
with an agenda they have an interest in
certain viewpoints being pushed forward
and then they want certain charismatic
people doing that um so the Breitbart
faction had million AA police he was
like their star and he was going around
as this gay guy who was married to a
black guy who was a conservative he
became big from gamergate which was this
push back against a PC wing of the
gaming community that wanted more women
in games I don't even know that I'm
under I think I'm approximating this to
a point where even if I'm getting a few
details wrong it's generally what
happened and she had you Napoli's
basically going online and pushing back
against the you know this the the the
people that wanted more representation
in video games it became known as
gamergate uh and then he went out and
and in he got popular he was funny he
was aggressive he didn't care he was a
troll he was a master troll he
eventually you know ended up going on a
college tour in America you know there
would be all
kinds of protests when he showed up the
famous one was at Berkeley when he went
to Berkeley you had a riot where I think
it was over $100,000 worth of damage
done to Berkeley and then eventually he
ended up getting the platform kicked off
Twitter because a lot of his fans he was
supposedly organizing his fans to go
after Leslie Jones I don't know if this
is true or not I don't care I'm gonna
make a bigger point that's it's neither
here nor there
I'm not a guy 4d platforming people and
and anybody who listens knows that and
that's why I didn't care that Legion had
them on or whatever and I really don't
care who has a platform I think
everybody has a platform and if your
arguments and ideas are better it's your
job to make them better and if and and
the other thing is that a guy like me
innopolis is relatively easy to defuse
if you're a smart person and you can
argue and by the way so Donald Trump
should have been - he also should have
been relatively easy to beat to be
honest but he wasn't for a lot of
reasons but this shouldn't have been
what it was like it shouldn't have been
this unbeatable guy that nobody could
handle literally towards the end they
just started asking him what are your
policies what do you want to do and he
had no answers and that was kind of the
way to beat him but he kept fighting
with him you kept playing his game and
then he won so you know obelisk gets
deep platformed off twitter he's you
know they kick him off patreon he's
kicked off I think Facebook I think he's
pretty much I don't know if it's as
quite as bad as Gavin McGinnis where it
was like he was unperson they remove you
from all social media immediately
instantaneously you lose all your
followers fans your ability to make a
living whatever Cemile oh um milah
whatever I keep going back and forth on
what that is he made a comment years ago
in a publication where he said in the
gay world there is mentorship that
happens that he was molested by a priest
at 15 years old and he does not view it
as a negative thing and in gay
relationships that is more commonplace
than you would imagine this is what he
said he said some version of that and
then he backtracked a little bit and he
said he was sloppy and he didn't make
the point the right way and I understand
and what he was saying first of all he's
never relation have is never an excuse
or an argument to ever have sex with
somebody's underage in any sexuality
that's not that's not I think that's not
what he was saying I think what he was
saying is that he personally as a victim
it didn't ruin his life
it didn't derail him in a meaningful way
and that he viewed it I think he said
there are certain types of relationships
uh in the gay community where a younger
guy is being shown the ropes by an older
guy because the younger guy can't really
go to his parents because his parents
are straight and heterosexual so the
older guy will like be like here are the
gay clubs he was this here's that which
is all funny good but this does not at
15 that's not what happens but I don't
think Mila was saying that it should
have but I think he was saying hey I was
[ __ ] at 15 or molested at 15 or
whatever so the right goes and gets him
the right digs up that article the
Reagan battalion were the people on the
right and they get me low they they they
and now it comes out people are saying
always pro pedophilia nobody cares about
the details but that's the society that
we live in the comment was an
unfortunate comment he didn't talk about
it the right way and him and Peterson
get into it it's actually a good podcast
but so he's gone then he's gone and he
spends two years essentially in
obscurity he's over the college tours
over he's Simon & Schuster whoever was
publishing his book I'm pretty sure it
was Simon & Schuster they pull out he's
done he's unable to continue making a
living he's the platform to off social
media he essentially goes away and now
he's starting to come back and he's on
Jordan Peterson and he's angry and he
said he's gonna come back now as a
comedian he's gonna come back he's given
up on politics for the most part because
he doesn't think the right and the
Conservatives had his back but you know
he said I'm a once in a generation star
I'm once in a lifetime star I'm gonna
come back I'm gonna be much more in the
realm of a regular entertainer somebody
like a Johnny Carson he goes to write
has nobody funny nobody that can crack a
joke and I I filled that
whole and and I need to again but I
don't care about politics anymore I'm
just gonna be I'm just gonna be somebody
who has his own late night show or
whatever and what you you get from the
interview his number one he's hurt he's
angry um he lost everything in one fell
swoop but what you also get from the
interview is that this is a guy who had
his baseline wanted to be famous this is
what he wanted to do this is not
somebody who was a political thinker he
didn't care particularly about politics
he accidentally got into it he was a
tech writer and then once he started
creating a lot of controversy he said I
can ride this wave to fame and to
fortune and the people behind him and
this is why I really want to make this
point the people behind him facilitated
that rise when you see people in the in
the public sphere and they all of a
sudden are everywhere seemingly
overnight it doesn't always happen by
accident it can it can happen by
accident but in many cases in most cases
and certainly when you look at
politicians you look at people like Mila
innopolis people like Candice Owens
people like Charlie Kirk and if you
don't know Candice issues the you know
the black conservative who's been on
Rogen and you know Charlie Kirk's the
guy that runs turning-point he's like a
younger kid these people are cast in
these roles by billionaire families like
the Mercer's like the cokes the same way
that a lot of the Parkland kids were
cast in those roles by interests on the
left wing how many kids graduated from
Parkland we know what eight of them who
are the rest of them where are they and
by the way I always wonder if the school
shooting happened in Long Island some of
these kids are pretty [ __ ] eloquent
they're pretty smart
they're pretty presentable they're hip
Emma Gonzales is bisexual at inks David
Hawk I mean you know if you if you shut
up my Long Island school and these
[ __ ] billionaire families were going
around trying to find
spokesman god help you god [ __ ] help
you if you stumbled upon me or my
[ __ ] friend
Yoda sure did was wrong but like
sometimes people need to get [ __ ] up
but I got it like shooting people in the
face is not good shoot him in the lake
there's there would be no there would be
not a soul that I went to school with
who would rise to that occasion it would
just be long I they would have to sift
through Long Island trash for an hour of
just like okay let's bring in let's
bring in Tracy Tracy how do you feel
about what happened yo I was like really
scared but the reality of the situation
is this I don't really give a [ __ ]
because I'm focusing on myself and I'm
focusing on I really want to do
cosmetics this is something I've always
believed in and the reality is my my
mother is like you should stop drinking
you should raise your daughter and I
tell her I'm like I can do both so what
I need to do is I don't really care
about the the [ __ ] shootings the
shadow I think you should ban guns I
think maybe I should have a gun quite
frankly folks I've told you before about
blue true and it's really something that
I think you need to do sex is very
important not seemingly to the younger
generation of people who've just decided
it's kind of a waste of time and that
procreation is a tool of the patriarchy
used to oppress people and time is much
better spent wielding power through a
nameless faceless online mob but that
being said there are some people that
certainly enjoy getting a little Nikki
but you gotta have everything working
everything's got to be a proper order
this is why you got a blue shoe calm
okay blue true calm is great blue true
is a the first chewable okay so you can
feel like it's like a Flintstones
chewable I feel like a kid and it can
even it could even be fun it's like your
mom could could be like listen you know
you know Dan won't take his viagra but
he loves his blue chew and then you're
just sitting in a high chair at 33 years
old and she's feeding you a blue chew
and you're chewing it and then some you
know fat skank comes over that you met
and you guys can just go
in the basement which is your room
but it's great you know it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form okay you don't have
to go to the doctor there's nothing like
that no embarrassing doctor visits and
awkward explaining to the doctor while
your dick doesn't work it shipped right
to your home and discreet packaging okay
blue true has medical professionals that
can easily diagnose and prescribe right
over their own website it's pretty
amazing you got to go to blue true calm
be lue ch GW blue chew calm promo code t
let me see what the [ __ ] promo code
is here because you guys should use it
it is promo code TD how easy is that
promo code TD blue shoe calm okay and
again this is this is everything's gonna
be great you're gonna have a big hard
dick you're gonna meet a lovely woman or
man or whatever you want to meet then
you're gonna sit down you can own a home
you're gonna have a retirement account
you're gonna go on vacation you know
you're not gonna live in this gig
economy hell that everybody else is
driving lyft and uber between their 15
jobs while they make no money and stop
only at red lights to a pint on a
controversy that doesn't affect them or
you know potentially upload a picture to
social media that make it seems like
they're not living in a hellscape even
though they are and every minute of the
day is spent trying not to relapse on
drugs or trying to save enough money so
that they can just buy a one-way ticket
to a third world country and join a
rebel militia okay you're not gonna be
one of those people what you will
probably be is very successful happy
well-liked well hung you'll just wake up
and have a big dick human-being so BL
you see HTW blue tree comm promoted a
but so the so that the Parkland kids the
ones that we've seen a remarkably
composed there's they're intelligent and
and by the way the people that are
casting these roles want these roles I'm
not saying they don't want them they are
auditioning to an extent I'm sure
Candace Owens Charlie cook mewling up
they wanted these roles
fortune money power people when you go
to an audition when most people go to an
audition there's hundreds of people
thousands of people I mean when I go
it's for fat comics we see each other
every [ __ ] time and they don't they
give it to someone else anyway
it's the same for fat idiots sitting
there going up would go in again and
then we say one we say two words they go
slate Tim Dylan six one please read the
line armed robbery
next they're like can you say it again
um
don't laugh into the mic people hate
your laugh I don't know why I mean not
everyone only one guy one guy complained
about your laugh but you can laugh just
try to laugh you know but this is this
is these are dishes I don't think it's a
bad laugh I don't know why everyone's so
mad out of [ __ ] you [ __ ] you one guy one
guy was like I want to kill that kid
because of his laugh but auditions are
filled with hundreds of thousands if you
don't want these [ __ ] jobs and
Mealing innopolis wanted the job
somewhere along the line the reality is
there are these different power factions
and people you know melee innopolis he
thought he was like I was speaking at
CPAC I was gonna be the standard-bearer
of this party of the Republican Party
he's gay provocateur who's married to a
black guy who's out of his mind he's
being deep platform he's all over the
place and basically the National Review
crowd in the Republican Party that were
more straight-laced a with the people
that didn't want Trump
they got me lo out of there and they de
platform to him but this is what you're
serving it's like you know when you have
a certain job in the administration of
the presidency they say you serve at the
pleasure of the president when you were
a guy like mewling Annapolis you're
serving at the pleasure of the Mercer's
you're serving at the pleasure of a
billionaire family I know how hard it is
to create a grassroots fanbase it's not
easy and when you're able to build one
very quickly and you get a lot of media
attention and you have a lot of
infrastructure you have a lot of
financial support you're flying around
the world more than [ __ ]
none of that is cheap and these people
are funded there's big money behind all
of these people and if they slip up or
somebody in an organization that's
backing them goes I don't think they're
the right person to get this message
out we're gonna get rid of them and then
they throw them overboard Emilia
innopolis he sounded a bit naive in the
interview of Peterson he sounded a bit
like he seemed to be like he was it's
like you know new to the party a little
bit it's like we you didn't think that
this could happen
how was he trying to defend himself how
was he cuz that was like a also wasn't
that like a three year old interview
yeah four years old they dug it up yeah
well what he was saying is that
conservatives are [ __ ] and they
didn't have his back and he was saying
that now they're gonna get taken out the
same way they took him out it's Kyle
issen it's not completely untrue that
they had there is now a way to take
people out you go and find something
they said and they're trying to try to
take Peterson out a bunch and has it
stock it has it worked but I do think
their move this they will move Peterson
to the center a little bit they're
moving them a little more mainstream
that'll happen and they'll do it just by
you know opening up avenues to him that
were previously closed and when those
avenues open up you you then have to
kind of temper your language and what
you're saying and you try because you
have this avenues you know that they'd
open up whether it's mainstream
publications or mainstream media um
academia whatever it is that you know
Peterson is a different animal than meat
than Milo it's just a different
situation you know Milo is really a
troll in a provocateur but they've tried
to take Peter sit out and this is and
listen they'll try to take chappy row
out they'll they they will try everybody
will try what I don't think people
understand in this country is that a lot
of what you're watching is theater this
is theater this is to keep you guys
entertained and the money people behind
this are just doing whatever they're
gonna [ __ ] do either way either way
they're doing whatever they're gonna do
mom
dad's who are those big billionaire
families they're doing whatever that
bedtimes whatever time it is you can
negotiate
you know maybe you stay out a little
longer whatever they don't care you're
not really moving them off their course
dramatically meaningfully and if you do
they will come the gnashing of teeth
will be extreme and this is like people
like the Mercer's people like the cokes
people like you know George Soros on the
other side they all have an idea of how
the world should be run and they don't
go out to people and say this is how it
is they recruit people and they take
applications and they cast people this
key there's one kid from parkland but
one right-wing kid from Parkland Kyle
Khrushchev who was how come we need more
guns I mean that guy God loved him that
dude he wasn't in the building that was
shot into he was in like another
building he's like listen we gotta I
love that because you know the NRA loves
de Lawd they're like wait you'll say why
you you'll do what you'll do what oh
really
great so he's out there saying arm
everybody give everybody automatic
weapon that's his answer just throw
those [ __ ] it's the Wild West kick
open the saloon doors at your own risk
buddy and so you have this kid now but
here's the thing Kyle loves saying the
n-word he loved it he said it on uh-oh I
don't know where he said it but he said
it on his snapchat he said no snaps
disappear what's the other I don't know
whatever but they got or it was a game
his gaming Xbox Live and the gay Xbox
Live he was letting it fly let it fly on
Xbox Live and in real life in real life
too he just walk up to people he would
say the n-word frequently so they found
that they went and go hey hey hey so
what happens
I think Turning Point USA I think he
resigned so again he's out because you
serve at the pleasure of the
billionaires who back
you that is it that is what your
attitude this is theater this is to keep
people entertained and to keep people
thinking that there's real debate and
discussion in this cut there really
isn't there's really not a lot of debate
and discussion about what's gonna happen
in this car I know you'd like to think
there is you're like this is everybody's
at each other's throats yeah maybe in a
[ __ ] grocery store but in Washington
DC they're pretty much on the same page
there's a few things that they like to
argue about abortion and Alabama and in
Georgia there's a few real hot buttons
should gay people adopt kid there's a
few things but when it comes to foreign
policy economic policy the rights of
corporate America they are pretty much
Nancy Pelosi in her georgetown town
house or with her millionaire husband
and San Fran we're [ __ ] Laurel Umar's
climbing in her kitchen window I mean by
the way how do you not like Laurel umer
a little bit how do you not respect
Laurel umer a tiny bit she's the chick
who takes it too far that she's the girl
on your block that would hang out with
the boys and would kind of do anything
if you know what I mean to have friends
like you'd be like eat this bullfrog and
she'd be like okay should I put it my
[ __ ] and you're like oh my god you'll
she'll just put it in your [ __ ] she's
like yeah I can hang out with you guys
right so this [ __ ] is climbing in Nancy
Pelosi's [ __ ] kitchen window because
they threw her off Twitter and again
none of it like it's none of it really
mad in an see Pelosi and Donald Trump
have a lot more in common with each
other and they have a lot more in common
with Stephen Colbert then people have in
common with uh you know of my uncle
Larry
for example uncle Larry doesn't have a
ton in common with Nancy Pelosi Trump
Colbert there's there's there's just not
a lot in common
but this is the thing that people love
to get involved they get invested
there's YouTube shows that cover the
beef of other youtuber like its and the
the internet is great because it really
does allow people to really feel and
listen did it elect Trump yeah there are
certain I'm not saying that there's
absolutely no effect but if you look at
what Trump has done he's done a lot of
things but there's a lot of things that
just haven't changed and won't change
and still you see people that have like
cognizant politically for the first time
they're they're all like wait wait a
minute
but Trump said it was gonna be a wall
and Wall Street was gonna be reined in
and we're gonna get a new health care
plan it folks it this isn't what happens
you gotta grow up a little bit the
people that are in those positions make
it very very difficult to make any real
change it's just the [ __ ] way it is
so what we do when we focus on Candace
Owen take Candace Owen say something
about Hitler
what did Roseanne tweeting oh I can't
believe Kyle khushu this 1700 I had no
idea who he was but he said the n-word
and these are the things you vote you
don't focus on what's truly happening
behind the scenes cuz you don't know
it's kept from you comes out in a book
ten years later or if you're really
really plugged in and you pay attention
you can you could figure out some of
what's happening you know like somebody
that I I I think was the chick on chapo
amber said was like you know hardcore
Marxist or whatever but she goes I love
the Financial Times more than the New
York Times she goes because I actually
glean more information it's a better
publication I learn more about what's
gonna happen in the world the Financial
Times is the world as it is and the New
York Times is that you know
editorialized rosy view of like well we
think of the law and the Financial Times
is that this is up this is down we need
a pipeline to the Caspian Sea energy
prices of crashing we might need to get
a little cute in a certain area we might
need to go over there like so there are
ways to figure out this information but
it is it is funny to me how much of it
is theater and and I know that people
get mad at me because you're like well
what am I supposed to do not care about
anything yes
yeah yes I yes
now I'm kidding listen care about what
you can care about I don't people tell
me all the time like what does it mean
so we shouldn't get health care like no
we should have health care like what
what are you even singing how does it
lunch today somebody strictly put it on
me for no reason I'm eating the pokeball
they go in on so dude turn of okay no we
should we should we should also not
torture people and underground prisons I
prefer if we didn't assassinate
democratically elected leaders in our
own country and around the world I would
like us to stop poisoning people
murdering journalists I would enjoy all
of that I would like if we stop sending
paramilitary death squads into other
countries so that they could make way
for our corporations going there pillage
people all of that and health care would
be nice it would be very positive for
this country but I'm telling you how
things like it is what it is the world
is what it is the things that I know
that people have had on the [ __ ] show
the discussions that we've had the
debate like the areas that we've gone
into you start to get a little coarsened
by this you start talking about human
trafficking you start talking about
what's going on you get a little corset
and it's not that difficult to like
imagine that like oh maybe some of these
senators or congressmen don't really
care about giving us elf care because
they're being blackmailed because
they're in the kitty porn and they're
doing blow so maybe they don't really
give a [ __ ] maybe they don't care I care
but here's the thing people like what do
you not care I can't I had people on
this show I had it gave them the
platform gave him a plug I had well
researched writers come on the show who
dedicated their lives to researching how
corrupt and [ __ ] our government was
and you know what people said they said
we don't want to listen to this we want
something else give us something else
give us a dope queen and the guy we
fought to give us something else give us
a pod save America we were going
elsewhere this ain't fun for the young
professionals going to their cubicles
they don't like that they don't like
that with their matcha latte and I
really like hearing about senators
boinkin kids and getting paid off and
you [ __ ] slaying Ken it so I try and
try I bring people on we did a lot we
did a live podcast you know showed up
not a lot of people we did one for truTV
we brought russ Baker on he was [ __ ]
all over the place I think he was kind
of drunk but this is what happens when
they cast you out of [ __ ] polite
society and you can't talk to anyone you
have a few so he comes on and he's
telling people the MK ULTRA and the
Boston Marathon bombing and there's
about a hundred young professionals in
suits staring at me him and ray comp
like you have no idea they were
completely lost they had no they were
like in their own head somewhere else so
when people say to me do I care yeah I
care and we we've actually tried in a
little way in our little shitty way
using this platform that we [ __ ] had
we tried to get people to give the
people don't give a [ __ ] they don't care
they want to be socialist they want to
be alright they want to be a thing and
they want a game and they want to be on
line with people to think like them and
they want to make memes and I want to go
get laid they go to the [ __ ] Brooklyn
red Socialist Party event mixer I'll go
down there and suck a few communists off
what do I give a [ __ ] but this is what
they want to do they don't give a [ __ ]
they really don't care they want to get
a patreon going they want money they
want Fame what they don't want is any
real [ __ ] air these are not
revolutionaries they're not gonna go
burn down the best yet it's not
happening the revolution isn't coming
look at the [ __ ] who say it is what
is and if we're gonna do they're gonna
throw a rock at what the White House
what are you nuts with some Fathead
green haired some fat green haired
lesbians gonna Chuck a [ __ ] chuck up
nunchucks at the White House and what do
you think is gonna happen
what do you think and who know you want
those people to rule they might be worse
but this is what I mean I'm sick of
wearing this mantle of I don't care no
you don't care you don't [ __ ] care
you don't see what Nick
Bryant this [ __ ] guy who's telling
you about torture all this [ __ ] for
hours you bring him on the show that
guy's got white hair he's telling you
you bring mark le Audion does a whole
book about the Russian mob and a Trump
and everything like that you know it's
like so the whole thing is I remember
stand-up at a great quote once and I was
like yeah people say I don't care but
seems like it didn't matter when I cared
remember when I cared no one gave a [ __ ]
so to me it's like listen do whatever
you want
go get health care go get everything get
get everything do whatever you want to
do I can't I'm not gonna say stuff
that's gonna get me in trouble here but
do what you want to do listen I said as
a joke this is a joke and I'm a comedian
but I said if you wanted to get the
government's attention this is a joke
and I'm a joker joke good joke good joke
but if you wanted to get the
government's attention you would strap a
bomb to a two-year-old and send that
toddler into a Grand Central every week
you would go to a different station and
a toddler would walk in and this is fun
I did this on stage was kind of funny
because I do it
toddler walk and it's very funny but a
lot of people don't laugh but it's very
funny to a few certain select people in
the room that are really they're really
over life so they think this shit's good
so I do the toddler walk and I go and
the toddler just she's got a little bear
attached to him but it's a bomb and he
just goes wild and then and then people
listen you're gonna get some attention
people will they'll be like these these
[ __ ] are willing to send in toddlers
to train stations at rush hour and blow
them up I'm not saying to do that like
when me and Ray told a bunch of our fans
to join Isis and move to Syria we did
that number one because I think you
should travel I think you should leave
I've said people should go teach English
in China and I've said if you feel
strongly about some I respect I don't
agree with Isis they've done horrible
things to gay people whatever but it's
hard for me to not respect if my friend
Ryan who's a you know personal trainer
and a DJ if he were to join Isis and be
in Syria and I saw a photo with him in
that Jeep Grand Cherokee with that
collision akov I would
a little proud I'd be a little proud
that he did it so when me and Ray said
go out there and join that we just said
listen you're all chirping all day on
Twitter go and I you know but I'm sick
of I'm no longer gonna take this [ __ ]
like I don't care and I've never you
know I know how [ __ ] up it is we tried
we told people I [ __ ] up people don't
get people don't really like that they
want like the SNL level of like it's
kind of silly that's what people want to
think about the government that it's
like a little silly it's it's silly they
don't want to think it's a murderous
death cult that's imposed they don't
they don't they don't I think I like to
think it is cuz to me that's funnier
than it being silly if it was silly it's
kind of stupid but when you when you
understand what it is you go it's kind
of like life means nothing to these P
you start laughing folks many of you are
still out there in the world without a
website I don't know how you're doing it
it's crazy but let me tell you right now
it's not gonna work I've told you that
before especially if you want the
boomers if you want older fans if you
want that generation of people that have
raped and pillaged ruined the world that
are all about to retire and [ __ ]
themselves and retirement homes all over
the eastern seaboard and really all over
the country if you want those people
figuring out where you are and what
you're doing you have to have a URL
gotta have a website this is the way it
is those people they love Facebook
because it's a website social media they
don't really understand they're not on
Twitch you're not gonna find them on
whatever the other one is that I've been
blanking on right now tick tock she's
just not gonna happen so you need a
website go to Tim Dylan's going to hell
comm TI MDI llo and s going to hell calm
there is no is in this site we built
this site for the for the podcast using
Wix okay you will see my live dates
coming up I'm at Mohegan Sun June 20th
to the 23rd i'ma hilarities in Cleveland
the 19th and the 20th
of July go to the website go all the way
to the bottom of the website and click
on the link and then upgrade or get it
get a Wix premium package or upgrade it
you're gonna save 10% if you take the
link from my website I'll tell you this
Wix is great
lots of people using Wix I think over
100 million have probably over 150
million have started websites with Wix
you could choose from over 500 templates
they have an dragon design on a DI which
is an artificial design intelligence you
don't have to do anything all you have
to do really is sit back answer a few
questions about what you want your
website to look like then Wix will do
the rest so for those of you who are
completely checked out don't even want
to do anything want a business want
people to know who you are
but don't even want to contribute to
your own website don't worry you can sit
back and let an alien artificial
intelligence design the entire website
for you ok they got AI to do what you
can't do
if you can't even contribute to your own
website if you're like hey listen I want
success but what I don't want is to
spend even 3 minutes choosing a template
maybe you're too busy maybe you're too
busy to choose a template will they have
that for you it's not great ok again Tim
Dylan's di ll o & S know is here going
to help calm also if you're listener of
the show you know that we have a
promotion where if you do this I will
have you on the show we're going to do
this episode next week too to watch
people call it to promote your product
whatever it is whatever you're using on
the website
whether you're a band or whatever Tim
Dylan's going to he'll calm if you
upgrade through my site I will give you
90 seconds on the show but you have to
prove it to me with a direct message on
Instagram showing that you've actually
done it through my site and then you
come on for 90 seconds and you could
plug whatever nonsense you're doing and
you'll get no audience of tens of
thousands of people that may be
interested all right that's what
take shrooms or anything and you realize
you just start looking at these demons
go to the watch George HW Bush's funeral
and watch the demons climb onto the
podium to eulogize him there 87 they've
drank human blood their entire life they
have soft skin the skin that comes from
eating the pineal gland of children and
they get up why do you think Comedy
Central hasn't given me a shot Lynne I'm
there I'm asking I'm asking literally
because I don't I don't know I think I'm
affable so these guys climb up on the
thing and they're like hi remember and
they're barely alive but they're just
animated by the demonic forces and they
climb onto the thing and they're that
harem mo and I first and and everything
about George HW Bush's life is a
complete fiction by the way and
everything about most of these [ __ ]
people's lives is a fiction okay
and it's perpetuated by a media and
whatever so these [ __ ] get and to me
the real story is funny that's why
that's one of the reasons I like it it's
absurd it's crazy it's funny and it
makes a lot more sense it makes a lot
more sense when you start realizing
you're like why did these congressmen
and Senators never give a [ __ ] about to
people in their districts and you go oh
they're all compromised many of them are
blackmail they're bought and sold and
then you start to understand how and why
then it makes a lot more sense when you
understand these things admit but when
you see these demons eulogizing HW and
they get out there they're like here now
I'm a charge years I'm a dam and they
and everyone in the room like they're
all kind of swaying and they've got
tears and the media's there too and
they're all crying because they all love
them because they're [ __ ] woody
they're all [ __ ] it's the same thing
they're all on the same crew it's the
same camp and so to me I've always so
when I heard me low like shock like I
love these people that are shocked that
you can be thrown away yeah yeah you can
be thrown away you can be taken out you
can be thrown to this you are not
essential
you know what I mean you're not
essential to the operation there's
somebody else waiting in the wings
waiting to take your spot so and so when
you know Appa list goes well I'm gonna
come back as a comedian and I'm gonna
host my own show on my own website fine
do whatever you want but that's what you
always were
you always were a comedian you never
were important politically it didn't
matter it seemed like you were you you
you you you helped maybe shift some
people's opinions on uncertain things
for a while but make no mistake this is
theater and you are a theatrical
performer you're not an essential part
of how this system were and it worked
for a long time when you just had the
major networks all of this was much
easier because these guys went to the
same schools they lived in the same
communities it's very easy to corral
people now it's harder but that's why
you hold the auditions and you get in
Charlie Curtin Canada so what am i
somebody I know like knows charlie Kirk
this is not somebody that I know well
like people listen to this show they
still have no idea who I am
they've no idea why I'm not like a woke
social justice yeah that's crying ha ha
so they they think I'm like a
country-club Reaganite or something like
I couldn't be be good charlie Kirk on
the show I said let me let me let me let
me
I've had people on my show that have
credibly accused the Bush family of the
murder of President Kennedy profiting
from the drug trade human trafficking
the overthrow of democratically elected
government murder genocide really I will
go into that if Kirk comes on my show we
are talking Franklin scant unseat
Charlie what so the bit I'll give them
one question I'm like tell us about our
low taxes help the business climate
you'll get so excited and I'll be like
all right so now that we've gotten that
out of the way let's get down to
business
I got a few testimonies you might want
to hear and I just pull the book out
page four I'll have a copy for him these
people are clowns took
clowns they're saying whatever they have
to say to make money don't fall for it
don't be that stoop they're just saying
they're actors they couldn't get into
Hollywood cuz their teeth are [ __ ] up
core tasks teeth [ __ ] they're there
they're in another you know there's a
quote that says like politics is acting
for ugly people show business for ugly
people this is what it is did say
whatever they say they don't care
Ann Coulter during who is funny but
mentally unwell and funny she during the
Iraq war was like CIA's gray FBI's great
we got to go and invade their countries
kill their leaders convert them to
Christianity that was the quote that got
her fired from the National Review now
the FBI and CIA are horrible they're all
infested with globalist shills that are
trying to get rid of President Trump we
should build the wall and we don't
belong in any of these [ __ ] countries
Syria whatever who cares if they're
gassing their own people let him do it's
not our problem she went 180 from all of
her views they don't care these people
don't care about anything they don't
have any values their value is relevance
that's all they give a [ __ ] about am i
near the bestseller list am I on the top
am I am I on the shows am I on the right
shows my on the sunday shows I'm a
getting invited to the right cocktail
party they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
believe in anything so don't [ __ ]
come at me when I'm trying to get a
Pokeball tell me that I don't give a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] Psychopaths
you nuts I've done the deep dives when
you think I don't give a [ __ ] cuz I'm
not getting on stage I don't have a a
half hour about socialized medicine the
[ __ ] you want me to write about my
mother's in a mental institution it
would be nice if that was nicer put a
couple of couches in there that are nice
I'd visit more I have no problem with
that stop acting like I'm corporate
shill I'm making no money people call me
a corporate message me on Instagram a
corporate shill for what corporation
gasps digital ink does that even exist
every day I'm waiting for the FBI to
come in and throw us in cuffs
I mean corporate shill people have
bananas out there I just want to be an
LA woman a fifth year old LA woman whose
entire life people want to [ __ ] her and
then they want to [ __ ] her they don't
really want to [ __ ] anymore so she
starts getting spiritual at 50 and she
starts talking about the journey and she
gets into meditation and health and
wellness and wholeness and being whole
because nobody wants to put anything in
her hole anymore and she didn't have to
think about any of that before she was
50 because everyone everywhere wanted to
[ __ ] her every door magically opened the
Sun rainbows appeared over her head but
when she got 50 in a couple of you know
the plastic surgery can hide a little
bit can hide it all can it so then you
have to get real deep and you have to
take that journey you know how long have
I done I want to say a few more things -
we're at 44 we're 44 that's perfect so I
got a I got a few more things to say to
the to the comedy community is a real
theater kid energy in certain parts of
the comedy community right now and I
will say that there's a lot of unearned
what's the word jubilance is that a word
jubilant people are very happy this is
my problem
I look at people sometimes they're very
happy well they think they're doing some
date well they're happy things are going
well but a lot of this is I was in
actors which I wasn't in high school
theater okay you talentless [ __ ] I
was a real actor I was on Sesame Street
and before you laugh at that you fat
checks you bunch of fat chicks trying to
get attention for the first time of your
goddamn life understand that I got paid
a lot and not often but I was paid I was
in real play that real people wrote I
guess some of them killed themselves
afterwards that's what playwrights do
they take themselves out okay they don't
go to junior foul and dance run they
blow their brains out New York was a
great city I was in a show called lake
of fire no I'm sorry
wasn't that but I was in another show
called Christmas dreamers awakened it
was about a woman who was raped by her
father repeatedly and it was in the
village when the village was cool it had
little black box theaters and I was in
this I think I was eight or nine or
something I don't even know what I did I
just kind of sat there while the main
character went on and just just hinted
about her dad raping her she never fully
but it was pretty if you if you were
intelligent you knew what was going on
her father came the show and he sat
there through the whole thing it was
clear that the main character was his
daughter and that he was the rapist he
molested everybody and she said what do
you think afterwards and he went I
thought it was good was a little long
and that and now that's been replaced in
Manhattan by theater kids theater kids
with PR departments behind them singing
and everything and there's way I feel
about it there's some real talent out
there even people I disagree with on
pretty much everything there's some very
talented people out there but this
there's a theater kid energy and the
theater kid energy is kind of like we're
the [ __ ] who cares
doesn't matter we're the new hot thing
we're great we live in this bubble we
enjoy it and it's all fine what I'm
telling you I'm gonna tell you this
there there is I don't care what is
going on at the moment for anybody there
are so many talented people in New York
City who you'll just never see you'll
never hear from and they will die
underappreciated unappreciated alone ah
and just you know what think about them
a little bit think about them a little
bit when you do in your interviews and
you're asked meaningless questions by
some other goon whose job it is to you
know and just realize that you're lucky
that Joan Rivers said some people out
there a [ __ ] very lucky your vet your
you're a whole lot of fine you're a
whole lot of fine you didn't invent [ __ ]
it ain't great it in a riot when you
perform like people aren't stomping
get their money back usually cuz no
money was exchanged but just know that
that's where it's at dogs relax okay I
will say a quote that someone said it
made me a little upset they said when
people copy me you know what I say I say
thank you but you no one's copying you
cuz you've done nothing and I don't mean
that in a dick way cuz this person I'm
talking about I think
there's talent there but you've done not
you've inspired no one you've done
nothing cut it out
just just relax enjoy what's happening
enjoy where you're at and realize
there's a cashier at CVS who is so much
more talented than you'll ever be and
she's got three kids and a husband that
beats her and you are in a position to
be fine and have everyone love it
just know that that's where it's at
don't get crazy be happy i listen to
could people could say the same thing
about me I am fine there's guys that are
funnier than me that'll never get
certain opportunities I've gotten and I
try to think about that I try to think
about a [ __ ] up life is not all the
time because you gotta you know you
can't
I'm not saying but certain people to go
out there and there's this just real
attitude that uh they've been around for
about five minutes and they act like
they've changed the game they've changed
the game and five minutes ago if they
were boof nobody knew gone who didn't
know but now they're here and they've
revolutionized everything daegu Tanvir
with the printing press they came out
and they gave people the idea that they
could live there's people out there that
they now believe they can be like me and
live and it's such a it's such an honor
to inspire people create can you cut it
out No
but nobody is out there it's a mirage
it's a black box nobody's in with some
fat chick from Ohio's now gonna move to
New York she was going to anyway she was
coming anyway stop just be happy I come
from the world if he had a real theater
not mommy and daddy paid money for camps
and they paid money for publicist real
[ __ ] theater great people that aren't
art [ __ ] tremendous and none of them
succeeded then they all end up [ __ ]
singing to old people in Long Island
half of them this is what happens you
get cocky and you start talking like
you're the [ __ ] it's just to me I just
say to myself oh it's not needed it's
not needed it's not mature it is what it
is I have a lot of respect I see a lot
of plays I see a lot of shows i watch a
lot of people you're not gonna know who
they are but they're [ __ ] great
they're great at what they [ __ ] do
and it's just a little it could be a
little aggravating when out of nowhere
somebody pops up and they tend to think
that they've paid they're paving the way
they're paving the way for Pete the ways
been picked none of us are paving the
way here it's been paved ru hi ru hi it
it is been paved is paid people are
coming down it's it's good it's good I'm
happy am I making sense yeah yeah yeah
like when we saw the ferryman like in
the front row and there was the the the
was it called when they come out and bow
that yeah you know the curtain call
whatever I forget yeah yeah they come
out yeah it's a three-high seven a
theatre I don't know what it's [ __ ]
call no I'm trying to think need that
the cast call the bow I get where I've
done it more than half these other
people here to make fun of me I can't
think right now [ __ ] just yell over
the Bush family for an hour
of scattered yeah but we saw the yeah
what I'm like embarrassed to be seen by
I don't even want them to see my face
well this write an article about you
that you're the boss now you're the boss
of the five families they're gonna write
an article that you're the boss and you
go I'm the boss now I didn't shoot
nobody I didn't run a successful
operation no racketeering no gambling no
murder no women do not but I'm the boss
and you know when I want people well
people emulate me they copied me I say
thank you
ah God ah God
what are you doing have a little have a
little dignity inject it into yourself
somehow a lot of people baby on face it
was a baby and you were like that baby's
done more than either of us the baby on
the ferryman is done more than me and
bad have done and made more money and is
more essential to the production in
every way no one cares what I go to
laugh bought if they come out before me
and go today we're gonna have a magician
who does magic with puppets the audience
would go nuts they fall out of their
seats they'd be twenty five thirty P and
more now cuz more people in knowing
where some of my fans would be a little
upset until he came out and did it did a
little bit with the puppet and then a
lot of them ago is it that is it
we're already here so I'm just saying I
respect a lot of different people a lot
of different kinds of comedy but I just
there's so yeah sometimes people ask me
to do articles or they'll pitch an
article to me they're like how is it
harder as a gay guy in comedy I'm like
I'm not doing this article like what's
it like when a gay guy works comedy
clubs I'm like oh I don't know like tons
of gay guys have done throughout history
what are you talking about right I mean
I remember one gay guy in New York is
like I was the first gay guy to work a
comedy club I'm like you know that's
provably untrue that's completely wrong
you saying that I
i I don't I don't hate on anybody you
get all you could press sweating about
you great just come unless here's the
other thing unless you were kidding
maybe you were kidding when you said
that and then if that was a case I feels
the little stupid now if you were
kidding if you were kidding when you
said that it's kind of funny and well if
I mean if that was a joke then the the
last quarter of the show was my joke
then I was kidding if you were kidding
then I was kidding but I don't know if
you were kidding and the point is this
it's AB larger point it's not the one
line it's the larger thing it was the
line a lot but it was a larger thing how
beautiful here isn't it's nice what are
we at now 55 55 folks
Tim Dylan comedy calm we have really fun
stuff coming up we have a lot of cool
[ __ ] happening I'm gonna be a comics at
Mohegan Sun July 20th through the 22nd
July 23rd I'll be at skank fest I'll be
doing some club spots in New York the
last week of June
I said June right June I said July June
22 28 second O'Higgins son in
Connecticut take it link in the profile
page of my Instagram July 19 2 xx
hilarities in Cleveland Ohio one of my
favorite clubs I absolutely love it
August 1st through the 3rd American
comedy company in San Diego a lot of
dates down south and August including
Charlotte North Carolina
Nashville gonna be down there at Zanies
comedy zone in Charlotte Nashville
zany's the stardome yes and I think
Huntsville Alabama or Hoover Alabama and
and somewhere else in Hoover Alabama all
of those dates are on the website you
can get tickets to all of that stuff Tim
Jay Dylan D I ll Owen
on Instagram and Twitter we update stuff
in the moment if I'm doing [ __ ] around
LA or if I'm doing stuff in New York
what is your information at Ben Avery is
good on Instagram and Twitter
Benjamin Avery net my website man is out
there producing editing to an all kinds
of [ __ ] if you need him if you need work
not war if you need work if you have
worked for him hit him up email them
maybe he's too busy maybe he'll be able
to do that don't email him if you're a
clown email him if you're a serious
person
[ __ ] sent some troll email unless
it's funny if it's funny he won't care
but I'm don't really don't jam up the
inbox but whatever we are gonna do the
episode I know that I a lot of people
are like where's not a scam with Wix are
you really a no it's not a scam I told
you something I'm gonna follow through
on my promise if you if you did what I
said you had to do which was go to my
website click on the link at the bottom
which was Tim Dylan's di ll ons going to
hell calm there's no is it's just Tim
Dylan's with an ass going out the
comments the wick site that we built for
the show and at some of my live dates on
it some media on it if you went to the
bottom clicked on the link got 10% off a
premium plan with Wix and the message
meet adder showed me that you're coming
on the show for 90 seconds you have
three minutes to pitch whatever project
you want you're in front of tens of
thousands of people you'll pitch
whatever project you want I may ask you
questions about it or I may be so
disgusted and horrified we hang up on
you know I'm sure I don't think we're
hanging up we're gonna ask you you're
gonna get more than 90 but 90s a lot
you're gonna get 90 to pitch 90 is a
good pitch it's too long it's really too
long for most of you most of you got 60
seconds in you at best I will say a lot
of people that did it yeah use the promo
code so if you if you can't even do that
I mean listen I here's reality I'm just
putting you on anyway I don't even know
I don't even know if my ad department
knows how the promo code work
listen I
I'm gonna put you on if you sent me a
screenshot that you did something you're
gonna be on the show I don't have the
[ __ ] time
to advertise who's lying and that's
advertised when do an investigation and
pull it up and see who's [ __ ] around
and who just took a picture of Wix or
what I listen we get to you we get to
you we're gonna do that episode is
coming up soon I would imagine we're
gonna record it next week I'm gonna put
it up on my Instagram story or on
Twitter and then after we've done the
episode two weeks later somebody's gonna
mess with me go lose the wit will pay
attention [ __ ] pay attention we're
doing it once and only once you guys are
gonna I swear to god at 45 seconds
you're gonna have nothing I swear to god
you're gonna [ __ ] nothing and it's 90
seconds to pitch pitch what are you
doing you think that was a joke if you
copy me you know what I say thank you
wait what you think that was a joke you
didn't read the article what are you
talking about the thing that I just
ranted about for 17 minutes it now if I
don't know if it's serious or not oh the
gay thing no what game what K thing did
I even talk about about the comic in the
article who said it's not gay the thing
when the comic goes when people copy me
you know what I say thanks oh I think
you're talking about the gay comment um
I don't know I have to tell me who said
that off mic and I could have some more
content I don't I I think it was serious
I'm just saying it sounds like I've
heard comics say crazier things than and
this is a talented person but it relax
it's just crazy why comics that say I've
changed comedy I've said stuff not stuff
like that but I've said stupid stuff
were I've just tried to be funny and it
came off weird and people are like what
you dude so you know I respect everybody
and and if you listen to this show you
know nothing could be further from the
truth than what I just said when I just
said that when that came out of my mouth
I I just said I respect everybody
nothing I've never been anything less
than that yeah jeez
easily i just said it i respected
everyone everyone's good no i don't mean
a word of that i don't mean a pause i
don't mean any of that there's not one
word of that that i mean but we are
where we are
yeah comic asked you last night how do
you post on instagram with like such
confidence yeah how do you post the
stories and you said you said could i
look at these people like animals i have
contempt for all the people so we just
do what we do and if you like it you
like it that's it
except you you know who you are
who's ever listening to this you you are
not i'm talking about everyone else them
you are gift from god
you're designed by jesus christ you are
the only fan i want and the only one I
need everyone else is a flaming pile of
dog [ __ ] who I want to see dismembered
on television I don't have television
but on a streaming service or social
media or something that's [ __ ]
relevant Tim Dilla comedy calm goodbye